as communities continue to work to
prevent new surges of covid including
from the fast spreading omicron variant
i've heard the call from chiefs and
communities for faster access to
financial resources to prepare for
outbreaks implement additional public
health measures and respond quickly to
covenanting cases to prevent widespread
infection
so to help with those efforts indigenous
services canada is flowing 125 million
of cova 19 public health funding
directly to first nations self-governing
and modern treaty holders across the
country to support their ongoing public
health efforts
this additional financial support will
help first nations in their efforts to
enhance their community surge capacity
to protect against covenanting
infections
some examples of how the money may be
used could include to administer
vaccines and boosters or to conduct
rapid testing it could also be used to
pay for surge staffing and other
resources food security or other
supports for people in isolation or
updating reviewing and activating
pandemic response plans
the funding can also be used in a
variety of other flexible means in a way
that communities determine that will
best protect their members
speed of support matters when a
community is under threat of an outbreak
and we will continue to support
indigenous leaders and communities as
they work to protect their members
the money will be allocated using the
indigenous community support fund
methodology and will include an
allocation to the first nations health
authority in british columbia the
allocation and its temporary
implementation criteria have also
included careful condition
considerations for needs of remote and
isolated first nations
the indigenous community support fund
also remains available to indigenous
communities and organizations this
needs-based fund gives first nations
inuit and metis communities and
organizations the flexibility to design
and implement community-based solutions
so that they can prevent prepare or
respond to the spread of coven 19 within
their communities
indigenous service canada regional
offices and regional medical officers of
health across the country remain
available to assist first nations inuit
and metis communities and organizations
if they need
get help with an outbreak or support
such as temporary infrastructure rapid
testing or ppe as of january the 18th
over a million
vaccine doses have been administered in
first nations inuit and territorial
communities and of those
over 85 percent of individuals aged 12
and up have received a second dose
only about 20 percent of adults have
received a booster dose
and over 40 percent of children aged 5
to 11 have received at least one dose
as of january the 19th there are 597
active cases in first nations
communities
sadly there have been a total of 588
fatalities with kovit since the
beginning of the pandemic